[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend hinein es ist etwas über
eine stunde her da hat wladimir putin
eine rede gehalten über die wir alle
noch lange reden werden die hatte es in
sich das war eine ganz spezielle
geschichtslektion aus putins sicht
unterm strich hat er darin der ukraine
das recht abgesprochen als eigener staat
zu existieren
er hat ausgeteilt und zwar in alle
richtungen gerade war das minsker
abkommen zur befriedung der ost ukraine
noch in aller munde der bundeskanzler
sprach davon in moskau als weg zur
lösung des konflikts das war vor einer
knappen woche jetzt ist das minsker
abkommen de facto am ende denn russlands
präsident erkennt heute abend die
gebiete der pro-russischen separatisten
im osten der ukraine als sogenannte
unabhängige volksrepublik 'nen an das
ist ein gewaltiger frau in richtung
ukraine aber auch in richtung frankreich
und deutschland die seit jahren an einer
friedlichen verhandlungslösung für eben
diese gebiete basteln für europa stellt
sich jetzt die frage was nun dazu mehr
gleich zunächst die lage heute abend von
christian slam in moskau
mit dieser unterschrift unter das dekret
schafft wladimir putin fakten die
weitreichende folgen haben werden für
die ukraine für europa für den
weltfrieden in anwesenheit der
separatistenführer die ebenfalls
unterschreiben erkennt russland ganz
offiziell die unabhängigkeit der beiden
selbsternannten volksrepublik bonn jetzt
und lohans an
ich halte es daher für notwendig eine
längst ausgereifte entscheidung zu
treffen die unverzügliche anerkennung
der unabhängigkeit und souveränität der
volksrepublik donetsk und der
volksrepublik nur an ich bitte die
föderale versammlung der russischen
föderation diese entscheidung zu
unterstützen und dann die verträge über
freundschaft und gegenseitige hilfe mit
beiden republiken zu ratifizieren
fast eine stunde redet putin und er hat
einiges zu sagen er beginnt mit einem
ausführlichen historischen abriss und
mit der erkenntnis die ukraine sei ein
integraler bestandteil der russischen
geschichte
die moderne ukraine wurde vollständig
und zur gänze von russland geschaffen
genauer gesagt vom bolschewistischen
kommunistischen russland dieser prozess
begann praktisch sofort nach der
revolution von 1917 und lenin und seine
mitstreiter machten das auf eine für
russland sehr grobe weise durch
abtrennung eines teils seines eigenen
historischen
territoriums
was der kreml bislang immer ablehnte
wird heute realität unabhängigkeit für
die vom prorussischen separatisten
besetzten volksrepublik in donetsk und
lugansk seit acht jahren tobt an der
frontlinie ein bürgerkrieg und heute
kamen die anführer der separatisten nach
moskau mit ihrer zentralen bitte die
sitzung des nationalen sicherheitsrates
war die inszenierte kreml für die
historische anerkennung lieber wladimir
wladimirowitsch im namen der
volksrepublik doch jetzt bitte ich sie
die donezker volksrepublik als
unabhängigen demokratischen legalen
sozialen staat anzuerkennen
putin teilt noch weiter aus und macht
keinen hehl aus seiner abneigung gegen
die demokratisch gewählte ukrainische
führung
das regime in kiew ist zur gänze ein
ergebnis des staatsstreichs von 2014
diejenigen die damals den weg von gewalt
und blutvergießen und gesetzlosigkeit
eingeschlagen haben akzeptieren und
akzeptierten es keine andere lösung für
das problem des donners als die
militärische lösung
wladimir putin hat heute fakten
geschaffen die in ihrer tragweite noch
nicht komplett absehbar sind
und dann müssen wir natürlich reden
bringen wir unsere komponenten mit dazu
und beginnen mit christian senn in
moskau christian wir haben sie in deinem
beitrag gerade gesehen das war keine
rede das war ja eigentlich eine
generalabrechnung die ukraine sei
integraler teil von russland hat putin
gesagt was will er damit bezwecken
er in der tat das war eine
generalabrechnung das war eine
vernichtung mit worten könnte man auch
sagen
die seifen die kamen wirklich im
sekundentakt wenn man kamen gar nicht
mehr mit und könnte über jeden einzelnen
satz jetzt hier ganz lange reden und
diskutieren was er damit gemeint habe
ich habe mal einige einige sachen
aufgeschrieben er spricht zb von den
neonazis in der ukraine von einem virus
aus nationalismus den das land erfasst
hätte kritisierte solidarischen system
im land
kritisiert dass vertreiben der der
russischen sprache und aus russischer
sicht besonders interessant kritisierte
die opposition und dass andersdenkende
verfolgt werden um jetzt nur einige
punkte zu nennen da war noch viel viel
mehr drin in dieser rede heute kann man
schon sagen war die gerichtet an das
eigene volk vor allem war die gerichtet
an die welt ich
glaube die waren natürlich ans eigene
volk gerichtet als rechtfertigen und
erklärung warum er diesen schritt geht
aber auch an die an die welt natürlich
alle sollen verstehen was er damit meint
und aus einer geschichtsdeutung und dass
er die europäische ordnung ändern will
hat er ja nie einen hehl daraus gemacht
insofern war das eine große erklärung
wie er die welt sieht wer europa sieht
wenn man sich in den letzten tagen oft
gefragt hat was will putin eigentlich
dann war das heute vielleicht ein teil
der erklärung wir haben die anwürfe die
vorwürfe richtung ukraine gehört axel
sturm ist für uns in kiew aktuell man
kann sich denken dass sie nicht
besonders gut ankommen werden in der
ukraine ist schon klar welche reaktionen
ist da ganz aktuell gibt
nein die kommen nicht sonderlich gut an
die kommen überhaupt nicht gut an und es
ist auch noch nicht absehbar welche
reaktionen es geben wird ich habe im
moment das gefühl das land ist so ein
bisschen in so einem zustand der perplex
ead der überraschung der nationale
sicherheit und verteidigungsrat tag
zurzeit natürlich unter führung von
staatspräsident selensky selensky hatte
auch wohl mit dem us präsidenten
gesprochen hatte wohl auch das wort
kriegsrecht fallen lassen daraufhin gab
es wohl das sagen einige medienhäuser
die ermahnung des us-präsidenten auf
zivile und friedliche mittel
zurückzugreifen
die ukrainische
generalstaatsanwaltschaft hat
angekündigt heute abend ermittlungen
aufzunehmen
wegen verstoßes oder verdacht auf
verstoß gegen die verletzung der
territorialen integrität des landes also
ganz viele maßnahmen wir warten jetzt
auf die rede von präsident selensky
vielleicht wissen wir dann mehr und dann
weiter nach berlin
theo es war ja und das ist eine knappe
woche her dass hoffnungssignal da
sprachen wir hier miteinander der
bundeskanzler hat das mitgebracht aus
moskau man dachte man könnte mit diesen
minsker abkommen ein weg richtung
frieden beschreiten jetzt diese rede wie
soll es aus deutscher sicht jetzt
weitergehen die aktion von vladimir
putin musste auch olaf scholz als
affront auffassen
ja einerseits und andererseits hat der
kanzler auch schon direkt nach dem
besuch in moskau klar gemacht dass
naivität im umgang mit putins
inszenierung wahrlich nicht angemessen
sei das noch eine bestätigung gebraucht
hätte dann kamen die ja heute in aller
brutalität in berlin hört man am abend
sehr deutliche worte das ist ein
massiver verstoß gegen das völkerrecht
ist gegen das abkommen gegen die
territorialen unverletzlichkeit der
ukraine das sagt auch die
außenministerin nördliches geht zwischen
den hauptstädten heute abend konkret nur
noch darum welcher teil der verabredeten
sanktionen jetzt in kraft tritt oder
auch vielleicht das gesamte
sanktionspaket die eu hat eben schon
sanktionen angekündigt also es ist nicht
mehr eine frage des ob sondern nur noch
wie viel und ab wann sanktionen kommen
und gleichzeitig wird das dringende
signal an die ukraine gesendet aus
berlin sich jetzt nicht provozieren zu
lassen so schwer das auch fallen mag
also die nächsten stunden sind extrem
wichtig theo vielen dank an die in dem
oft die europäische seite gucken wir
gleich noch mal ganz besonders in dieser
sendung erst mal bringen wir washington
noch mit rein elmar theveßen wenn man
sich diese putin rede genau angehört hat
da waren das schwerste vorwürfe an den
westen drin unsere vorschläge seien
ignoriert worden
hat er gesagt und es seien phrasen aus
dem westen dass jeder staat selbst
entscheiden können welches bündnis er
wünsche sieht das weiße haus da noch
chancen für diplomatische lösungen
ich glaube nicht das weiße haus sagt
ganz klar das ist ein bruch des
internationalen völkerrechts
gleichzeitig eine endgültige absage auch
an das minsker abkommen putin will
eskalieren das ist die haltung hier vor
wenigen minuten hat der us-präsident mit
olaf scholz und auch mit emanuele marcon
telefoniert kurz davor eben auch mit
würde mir selensky der us präsident wird
jetzt ein exekutiv befehl unterzeichnen
hören wir aus dem weißen haus der wird
dafür sorgen dass keine amerikanische
firma keine amerikaner irgendwelche
geschäfte mit diesen regionen in der
ukraine machen darf und gleichzeitig
auch autorisieren dass sanktionen
verhängt werden können gegen jedermann
in diesen gebieten die mit den russen
zusammenarbeiten die usa sind sehr
besorgt darüber dass eben die
souveränität der ukraine in zweifel
gezogen wird deswegen geht man
eigentlich auch von einer weiteren
eskalation aus und da das ist das klare
signal aus dem weißen haus wird man das
gesamte sanktionspaket auch ausziehen
dass man mit den europäischen
verbündeten gesprochen hat ganz
herzlichen dank bis hierhin an unsere
korrespondenten und dann gibt es jetzt
ganz aktuell eine erste reaktion der
bundesaußenminister in zum thema
annalena baerbock ist in paris
wir fordern russland auf die
entscheidung rückgängig zu machen und
den weg wieder frei zu machen zu
diplomatischen und politischen
konfliktlösung im sinne der minsker
vereinbarung zurückzukehren wir erneuern
überdies unsere dringende aufforderung
an russland die militärische drohkulisse
an der grenze der ukraine abzubauen wir
waren ausdrücklich vor weiterer
militärischer eskalation durch russland
herzlichen dank
die bundesministerinnen gerade eben in
paris einigkeit das ist ja das mantra
der europäischen union in der
derzeitigen lage wir sind gemeinsam
entschlossen
wer genau hinsah und hinhörte heute beim
außenministertreffen entdeckt er
allerdings erhebliche unterschiede bei
entscheidenden details und nach putins
rede heute abend ist die reaktion der
europäer jetzt sehr akut aus brüssel
florian a
der tag an dem der krieg in der ukraine
vielleicht einen schritt näher gekommen
ist beginnt in brüssel in einem sehr
engen gang im zweiten stock des eu
ratsgebäudes
warten auf den gast des tages zum thema
dieser tage der ukrainische
aussenminister dimitrow cholera ist nach
brüssel gereist selbst kurz überrascht
über den medien auflauf und dann sehr
selbstbewusst
ja ich habe die eu aufgefordert jetzt
schon zumindest einige sanktionen gegen
die russische föderation sich verengen
denn dafür gibt es genügend gründe
noch ahnt cool aber nicht wie aktuell
seine forderungen an diesem tag werden
wird dennoch an diesem morgen setzen die
meisten eu aussenministerinnen und
minister er auf worte auf appelle statt
auf sanktionen
ich appelliere eindringlich an die
russische regierung an den russischen
präsidenten
spielen sie nicht mit menschen leben
sanktionen sind eine reaktion ist eine
bestrafung war sowie das kann man nicht
im vorfeld machen sollte man noch nicht
die sitzung der außenminister der zehn
stunden an ihrem ende sieht die welt
wieder anders aus es kursieren erste
informationen putin werde die
separatisten gebiete offiziell
anerkennen und dann
geht das ist es das passiert werde ich
das vereinbarte aktionspaket auf jeden
fall auf den tisch legen
das sanktionspaket kein tag verging in
brüssel an dem nicht gerätselt wurde was
eigentlich drin steht oft blieben
eu-vertreter so bewusst und eindeutig
wie heute der dänische außenminister
richard lee wir sollten keinen zweifel
lassen dass wir reagieren werden mit den
verheerendsten sanktionen die man jemals
gesehen hat als sicher darf gelten dass
die sanktionen menschen aus dem umfeld
des russischen präsidenten treffen
werden relativ sicher mittlerweile auch
dass die gaspipeline nord stream 2 von
russland nach deutschland nicht mehr in
betrieb gehen dürfte aber die schärfste
waffe sitzt vor den toren brüssels
die zentrale des internationalen
zahlungssystem swift und deutet man die
kommissionspräsident hin richtig dürfte
russland aus diesem zahlungssystem
ausgeschlossen werden
finanzsanktionen bedeuten für den kreml
dass wenn sie militärische aggression
gegen die ukraine fahren
russland im prinzip abgeschnitten wird
von den internationalen finanzmärkten
sieht europa jetzt die sanktions karte
als putin am abend seine rede hält sind
die ministerinnen und minister längst
abgereist man darf davon ausgehen dass
sie sich schon wieder austauschen
ja das tun sie denn jetzt hat die eu
angekündigt dass es sanktionen geben
werde florian hahn brüssel guten abend
welche werden das seien
ja erstmal so heißt es in der
pressemitteilung die gerade vor einigen
minuten veröffentlicht worden ist geht
es um sanktionen gegen diejenigen die an
dieser handlungen beteiligt waren da
steht in der pressemitteilung der eu
kommissionspräsident sinosol von der
leyen und des eu ratspräsidenten
spanische es dürften also sanktionen
werden gegen das direkte umfeld von
wladimir putin ja möglicherweise auch
gegen den russischen präsidenten selbst
aber das wissen wir noch nicht eine
genaue sanktionsliste liegt uns noch
nicht vor aber wir können sagen europa
hat sich auf diesen fall auf diesem tag
wirklich akribisch vorbereitet dass
sanktionspaket in allen einzelheiten
diskutiert und offenbar auch sehr sehr
gut abgestimmt denn so kann man
zumindest an diesem abend an diesem
ersten abend einer eskalation auch sehr
abgestimmt und sehr schnell auch
reagieren aber eben nicht mit dem vollen
paket mit den vollen sanktionen wir
haben es gerade gehört etwa von 90 m2
oder von dem ausschluss aus dem
zahlungssystems trifft sondern erst mal
eben nur in anführungszeichen nur mit
sanktionen gegen personen aus dem umfeld
denjenigen die an diesen handlungen
beteiligt waren das ist die erste
reaktion brüssels an diesem abend
florian herzlichen dank dafür ganz
aktuell live aus brüssel
was ist das für ein tag versuchen wir an
dieser stelle eine erste bilanz mit
carlo masala er ist professor für
internationale politik an der
universität der bundeswehr in münchen
herr professor guten abend
schönen guten abend herr sievers was
erleben wir da gerade ist das noch ein
polit schauspiel ist das psycho krieg
oder ist das noch mehr
naja ist es zunächst einmal also es ist
nicht überraschend dass putin heute
diese beiden gebiete anerkannt hat er
behält weiterhin die eskalation dominanz
er behält das heft des handelns in der
hand und sie sehen ja letzten endes wie
aufgeregt der rest der welt auch seine
rede reagiert hat guten behält es in der
hand ob er eskalieren oder deeskalieren
wird und von daher ist das ein
strategisch und taktisch momentan
ziemlich cleverer schachzug den er da
verzogen hat und ist es quasi so was wie
ein rhetorischer unterbau wenn man so
will für einen möglichen russischen
einmarsch in die ost ukraine etwa oder
warum jetzt diese generalabrechnung aus
dem kreml in aller öffentlichkeit
na ja zunächst einmal bekommt ja schon
seit langem nicht das was er will
nämlich harte garantien seitens der
vereinigten staaten und der nato dass
die ukraine niemals mitglied der nato
werden wird er bekommt nicht den rückzug
amerikanischer truppen aus mittel und
osteuropa all diese zentralen
forderungen werden nicht erfüllt also
dreht er die eskalationsspirale weiter
zusammen mit dem narrativ dass er heute
noch mal in der rede wiederholt hat das
dort einen genozid an der russischen
bevölkerung
vollzogen wird behält er sich hier
weiterhin die option in der hand
demnächst militärisch zu intervenieren
sollte die ukraine und das ist ja in
ihren berichten schon angekündigt worden
sich jetzt nicht extrem zurückhaltend
und den versuch unternehmen diese
gebiete militärisch zu erobern oder sich
auf scharmützel mit
den separatisten in der ost ukraine
einzulassen er behauptet es gäbe ein
genozid er nimmt da wirklich größte
worte in den mund auf der anderen seite
sie haben gerade ja selbst angesprochen
ist ja nicht davon auszugehen dass die
nato plötzlich den forderungen aus
moskau die ja sehr sehr weitgehend sind
und quasi die gesamte europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur zurückdrehen
würden um
dass die nato darauf eingeht deswegen
die frage an einem tag an dem auch das
minsker abkommen auf dem ihr viele
hoffnungen lagen de facto tot ist welche
möglichkeiten sehen sie denn jetzt noch
für verhandlungen
also sollten die vereinigten staaten und
die nato nicht hier zu einer position
kommen die putin das gibt was er will
insbesondere sozusagen die offizielle
zusicherung dass die ukraine niemals
mitglied der nato werden wird sehe ich
mittlerweile überhaupt gar keinen
handlungsspielraum für verhandlungen
mehr sondern es wird letzten endes auch
eine begrenzte militärische eskalation
hinauslaufen die diese beiden gebiete
betreffen wird sowie die schaffung
möglicherweise einer landbrücke von der
krim zu zum don bass und putin hat heute
selber in der rede gesagt und das sollte
man nicht unterschätzen
sie werden uns sanktionieren was wir
egal was wir machen und wir sind darauf
vorbereitet also die frage ist inwieweit
sich die russländischen föderation nicht
auch akribisch vorbereitet hat auf die
sanktionen die da kommen werden muss
sich jemand wie zum beispiel der
deutsche bundeskanzler jetzt an der nase
herumgeführt vorkommen an diesem
heutigen abend
ja ich denke sozusagen die bedeutung der
bundesrepublik deutschland aber auch
frankreichs in dieser letzten wochen lag
halt im in minsk abkommen und die
normandie format putin hat beide am
nasenring durch die manege geführt und
für uns deutsche ist es letzten endes
auch das offensichtliche scheitern von
16 jahren ostpolitik also die schon
unter hat angela merkel begann die fast
ausschließlich auf moskau als
verhandlungspartner gesetzt hat ein
denkwürdiger abend wenn man ihnen folgt
hat professor geben wir vielleicht noch
mal ganz konkret die praktischen folgen
ein bisschen durch die sind ja
vielleicht nicht für jeden sofort klar
da erkennt also ein russischer präsident
heute die separatisten gebiete in der
ost ukraine an die sind dann aus seiner
sicht nicht mehr teil der ukraine wozu
führt denn das jetzt ganz konkret am
boden
also zunächst einmal wird es sicherlich
dazu führen dass das was bisher gelaufen
ist weiterhin läuft also es werden
weiterhin pässe ausgegeben es wird die
ökonomische hilfe für diese gebiete
erhöht werden aber vor allen dingen ist
jetzt aus russischer perspektive
die legitimation eines eingreifens zum
schutz der dort lebenden russen sowie
die russländischen föderation das sieht
einfach nochmals erhöht worden und
schafft von daher sozusagen
legitimation möglichkeiten für
militärische intervention und
gleichzeitig aber auch eine dauerhafte
die stabilisierung der ukraine sehr
wichtig mit blick auf eine zukünftige
nato mitgliedschaft der ukraine sagt
professor carlo masala von der
universität der bundeswehr hat professor
herzlichen dank für diese einordnung in
einem sehr schwierigen nachrichten tag
ich danke ihnen und
das thema krone hat hanna jetzt im blick
ist bestimmt den ersten teil der
kurznachrichten und da starten wir mit
england wurde jetzt die letzten
staatlichen corona maßnahmen fallen das
heute heute premierminister johnson im
britischen parlament angekündigt ab dem
februar müssen positiv getestete in
england nicht mehr zu hause bleiben und
sich isolieren wegfallen sollen außerdem
die kostenlosen schnelltests johnson
setzt darauf dass sich infizierte selbst
verantwortlich verhalten sowie bei
anderen infektionskrankheiten opposition
und experten kritisieren das ende der
maßnahmen als zu voreilig und
geöffnet wird auch in australien und
zwar für internationale touristen fast
zwei jahre lang waren australiens
grenzen für urlauber geschlossen aus
angst vor dem corona virus doch die
abschottung hat nun ein ende
seit heute dürfen touristen wieder
einreisen voraussetzung ist ein gültiges
visum und ein vollständiger impfschutz
gegen das koma virus eine booster
impfung dagegen nicht australien gehört
weltweit zu den ländern mit den
strengsten einreisebestimmungen während
der pandemie
noch am freitag hatte
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
angekündigt dass eine erste lieferung
des neuen corona impfstoffs nowaks heute
in deutschland eintreffen soll nun sagt
sein ministerium geliefert werde im
laufe der woche
1,4 millionen dosen sollen dann an die
bundesländer verteilt und ab kommender
woche vererbt werden zuallererst an
ungeimpfte beschäftigte in kliniken und
in der pflege kovacs unterscheidet sich
von den m rna impfstoffen er ist protein
basiert also so produziert wie ein
klassischer impfstoff zb gegen grippe
die hoffnung ist dass dies bisherige im
skeptiker überzeugt sich immunisieren zu
lassen
diplomatie ist eine zutiefst menschliche
angelegenheit es geht darum
gesprächspartner in die augen zu schauen
aber auch hinters gesicht das hat der
scheidende deutsche botschafter in wien
ralf beste jetzt dann im interview mit
der österreichischen wochenzeitung
falter gesagt in die augen schauen und
auch hinters gesicht das geht eben nur
persönlich und direkt schulbuch beispiel
des botschafters dafür ist eine
diplomatische sensation die heute exakt
50 jahre her ist da stieg der damalige
us-präsident richard nixon plötzlich in
peking aus dem flugzeug nach
jahrzehntelanger feindseligkeit und
praktisch null kontakten zwischen beiden
ländern es war ein meilenstein der die
weltordnung neu aufstellte und heute 50
jahre später weder in peking noch in
washington groß begangen wird weil die
beziehungen usa china auf einem neuen
tiefstand sind el mati wissen
es ließ sich gut an an jenem 21
februar vor 50 jahren kaum wurde richard
nixon vom chinesischen premierminister
chennai begrüßt da erreichte ihn die
nachricht der vorsitzende mao präsident
nixon sehen es folgte das gespräch dass
die usa und china lange zeit zu partnern
machte und hatte gemeinsame feinde zb
die sowjetunion was den chinesischen
kommunismus an ging auf die washington
auf wandel durch handel und durch den
profitierten beide seien
als vize präsidenten trafen sich 2012
shipping & joe biden der nannte den
chinesen offen und konstruktiv
doch damals änderte sich etwas 2015
stand sie mit obama im rosengarten des
weißen hauses versprach dialog
kooperation aber auch etwas was er nicht
wirklich halten wollte china sagte er
hat nicht die absicht den indopazifik zu
militarisieren
[Musik]
china begann dann mit einer strategie
des zwangs in der region operationen in
der grauzone was sie in bezug auf das
südchinesische meer sagte war also nicht
die wahrheit
tatsächlich kommen die rgi mittlerweile
die größte kriegsmarine der welt und
überall raketen die us flugzeugträger
zerstören können korallenriffe ließ sie
zu inseln aufschütten und
militärstützpunkte zu errichten und
immer wieder droht er taiwan
zurückzuholen in das reich der mitte
notfalls mit gewalt beim virtuellen
gipfel im dezember kritisierte beiden
das häufige eindringen chinesischer
kampfflugzeuge in die schutzzone um
taiwan der partner von einst ist jetzt
amerikas ribar in der brandneuen
indopazifik strategie des weißen hauses
heißt es chinas erpressung und
aggression umspannt den globus aber ist
einmal testen im indopazifik und weiter
unser ziel ist es nicht china zu
verändern aber wir wollen die
strategische umgebung gestalten in der
es operiert
diesem zweck dient auch der u boot deal
amerikas und großbritanniens mit
australien das land wird seit über einem
jahr von china mit wirtschaftssanktionen
drangsaliert
dass diese beiden sich kürzlich
gegenseitige unterstützung zusicherten
gilt als alarmsignal offenbar halten die
beiden autokraten amerika und seinen
präsidenten für schwach
peking schaut sich sicher genau an wie
die usa in bezug auf russland und die
ukraine vorgehen wie stark ihr
politischer wille ist je nachdem was die
vereinigten staaten da machen könnte
dass ihr vorgehen gegenüber taiwan
beeinflussen
im februar vor 50 jahren vereinbarte
chennai mit nixon die ein-china-politik
und genau die könnten joe biden nun bald
platzen lassen um china abzuschrecken
von einem einmarsch in taiwan
es gibt probleme an vielen ecken dieser
welt und die sorgen über ständig
steigende preise die werden mit dem
heutigen tag auch nicht kleiner geworden
sein und dabei gibt es die schon viel
länger hanna rohstoffe und
industrieprodukte wie erdgas holz oder
zum beispiel metalle sind deutlich
teurer geworden
die erzeugerpreise sind im januar im
vergleich zum vorjahresmonat um 25
prozent gestiegen und damit so viel wie
seit 1949 nicht mehr fragen wir nach bei
frank bethmann an der frankfurter börse
woran liegt und was heißt dass am ende
für uns verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
naja die mischung macht so brisant da
sind die seit monaten gestörten
lieferketten hinzu kommen die ebenfalls
seit geraumer zeit steigenden
energiekosten für die es zahlreiche
gründe gibt nicht nur den sich
zuspitzenden ukraine konflikt unterm
strich hat dies alles für die industrie
viele rohstoffe und vorprodukte deutlich
verteuert nur eine auswahl binnen
jahresfrist legten düngemittel und
stickstoffverbindungen um 67 prozent zu
well papier und wellpappe kosteten 42
prozent mehr und gas heizöl und strom
zusammen betrieb ist ebenfalls um 67
prozent nach oben welche kostenexplosion
ihn am meisten stört daraus machte bdi
präsident siegfried russwurm heute
keinen hehl die energiekosten steigerung
sind so hoch wie seit der ölkrise der
70er jahre nicht mehr in den rasant
gestiegenen energiekosten sehen 88
prozent der vom bdi befragten 400
unternehmen eine starke oder sogar
existenzielle bedrohung die so immens
gestiegenen erzeugerpreise sind aber
auch für die verbraucher eine schlechte
nachricht gelten sie doch als vorläufer
für die entwicklung der inflation teile
dieser enormen preissteigerungen werden
nämlich mit sicherheit an die
endverbraucher weitergegeben
da fehlen dem dax heute die argumente er
verliert zum wochenbeginn deutlich 2%
oder über 300 punkte
kinder nach frankfurt
erster linie dann sein app jetzt antonia
gleich drei sturmtiefs fegten in den
vergangenen tagen über deutschland und
hinterließen große verwüstungen die
schäden der sturm serie dürften die
versicherer nach ersten schätzungen etwa
anderthalb milliarden euro kosten auch
in der vergangenen nacht stürzten bäume
auf häuser autos und oberleitungen in
mehreren bundesländern rissen die böen
dächer ab im bahnverkehr gab es erneut
zugausfälle und verspätungen und in
norddeutschland standen wieder ganze
landstriche unter wasser
bei einem großbrand in essen ist in der
nacht ein wohnkomplex in flammen
aufgegangen alle bewohner konnten in
sicherheit gebracht werden drei menschen
wurden leicht verletzt
offenbar war das feuer auf einem balkon
ausgebrochen warum ist bisher unklar
angefacht durch heftigen wind habe sich
der brand rasend schnell ausgebreitet
erklärte die feuerwehr
35 wohnungen brannten völlig aus weitere
wurden beschädigt die löscharbeiten an
dem einsturzgefährdeten gebäude dauern
an
ja das war ein sehr denkwürdiger
nachrichten montag vielen dank dass sie
mit uns dabei waren und gegen null luft
jetzt meldet sich hier nah sagt er mir
mit unserem heute-journal update wenn
sie wollen gerne bis morgen für heute
ihnen einen angenehmen haben
[Musik]
guten abend sturmtief antonia verlässt
uns immer mehr in richtung osten jetzt
gibt es noch kräftige schauer und
gewitter und morgen bringt uns tief baby
regen heute nacht also kann es glatt
sein auf den straßen bei temperaturen
zwischen plus vier und minus ein grad es
gibt noch weitere kräftige schauer
morgen vormittag sind wir letzten
schneeregenschauer südostwärts ab dann
wird es freundlich bevor von westen
neuer regen herankommt und oberhalb von
etwa 600 meter kann es auch schneien bei
vier bis elf grad am mittwoch wird es
dann von westen deutlich sonniger aber
schon donnerstag und freitag werden
wieder wechselhafter und dann kann es
auch wieder leicht schneien manchmal
fällt schnee ja auch ganz überraschend
wie vor zehn tage hier in peking was uns
zur klimawandel frage führt welche
zukunft haben olympische winterspiele
nach einer aktuellen studie der uni
innsbruck wird von den bisherigen 21
winterspiele austragungsorten zum ende
des jahrhunderts nur noch eine faire und
sichere bedingungen bieten können und
zwar das japanische sapporo schon in den
2000 50er jahren kämen in europa nur
noch der hammer oslo und albertville in
frage selbst wenn die pariser klimaziele
eingehalten werden auch in einem
wärmeren klima wird es ab und zu mal
schneien wenn auch immer seltener
statistisch wird der schnee im
spätwinter jedoch viele wochen weniger
lange liegen und bis in die mittleren
lagen der alpen mehr und mehr abnehmen
für österreich gilt das bis mitte des
jahrhunderts nur noch oberhalb von 1500
meter skibetrieb verlässlich möglich
sein wird guten abend